clouds and dirt I spend all my time in
the clouds in the dirt the clouds are
the high-end philosophy and beliefs that
are the heart of everything I am and
everything I do
if you religiously follow just a few
core business philosophies that mean the
most to you and spend all your time
there everything else will naturally
fall into place the dirt is about being
a practitioner and executing towards
those clouds it's the hard work the vast
majority of people tend to play to the
middle which is why they usually only
succeed up to a certain level and then
Plateau ideas are worthless without the
execution execution is pointless without
the ideas there are too many people who
are average at what they do and then
confused by their average results
everyone has their own definition of
thousand dirt but if there's any advice
I can offer you that will change the
entire trajectory of your career it's a
start pushing on both edges raise the
bar on your business philosophy dig
deeper into your craft you want to be an
equally good architect as you are
amazing you've got to be able to
simultaneously think at a high level and
get your hands dirty there are too many
prima donnas out there who think that
they are the brains of the business and
they don't have to get their hands dirty
don't get caught up in this
even as you start to taste success you
have to have the humility to get on the
middle aisle seat to the Philippines and
sell a few bottles of wine some random
restaurant on any given day I sit
through four or more pitches and the
pitch I usually end up liking the one
where the players are actually doing the
work they're in the trenches they're not
just doing the big holistic thinking or
the higher-level branding they're just
at a raw level executing they're
engaging like mad and experimenting and
trying things that risk getting them
ridiculed there really aren't that many
people who are hard practitioners like
that there also aren't that many people
who are looking far into the future I'm
talking twenty twenty-five and twenty
thirty everyone is hanging in the middle
space trying to get the most in the
short term instead of trying to build
something that lasts to be in the middle
is to be like everyone else it's safe
the middle keeps everything going away
it always has the clouds and the dirt
breaks things up you surrounded by the
middle for 99.9% of your life
most things are unremarkable I want you
to lose yourself in the clouds in the
dirt and figure out what you can make
that change
bigness sucks lack of Drive sucks
half-assing things suck and so does the
minute Wow